hi my name is Paul Newsome and I'm a
developer advocate for the Google cloud
platform almost all applications need to
use some kind of persistent durable
storage to get their job done this might
be to store information about user
accounts images you want to capture or
serve a time series of events that is
happening that you want to analyze or
pretty much any type of data you can
imagine not surprisingly the Google
cloud platform can store all these
things however because different
applications have different storage
requirements the Google cloud platform
has not one but several ways of storing
persistent data today I'm going to
introduce each of the storage options in
the Google cloud platform and talk about
their different characteristics to give
you some idea of which ones you should
use for your application note that
depending on your application you might
use one or several of these storage
services to get the job done let's start
our tour in the Google developers
console I should mention that we are
constantly improving the developers
console to add new features and improve
usability so don't be surprised if the
console you see looks different from the
one shown here you should be able to
perform similar tasks to what I
demonstrate here today in future
versions of the developer console here
we have a new project I recently created
in the left navigation menu we see the
major categories of services offered by
the Google cloud platform including
storage under storage we see four of the
storage services offered in the Google
cloud platform cloud BigTable cloud
datastore cloud sequel and cloud storage
there is a fifth storage option that is
not listed here but is instead under the
Big Data heading bigquery bigquery is
both a storage service and a powerful
analysis service which is why it is
listed under Big Data we can divide
these five storage services into two
categories structured and unstructured
if the data you want to store can be
organized into a table structure with
columns and rows than it is structured
data examples might be user profile
information event logs sensor
measurements sales records or stock
trade data
structured data comes in many different
shapes sizes and usage patterns and
there is a great diversity of ways to
store it and interact with it so perhaps
not surprisingly all but one of the
storage services offered by the Google
cloud platform are for structured data
cloud sequel cloud datastore cloud
BigTable and bigquery all store
structured data
the remaining storage service Google
Cloud Storage stores unstructured data
by which I mean that you give cloud
storage a sequence of bytes to store a
place you want to store it and a name to
identify that sequence of bytes and it
stores them for you of course there may
be internal structure to that sequence
of bytes for instance it could be a zip
archive with a table of contents and
individual archives inside of it or it
might be a JPEG image file which has a
well-defined format or even a text file
in CSV format organized into rows and
columns which sounds a lot like
structured data the key is that cloud
storage has no insight into that
internal structure it just faithfully
stores and retrieves the exact sequence
of bytes you ask it to regardless of any
internal structure that may exist in
those bytes at this point you might be
thinking this unstructured data you're
talking about sure sounds a whole lot
like files and you'd be exactly correct
but cloud storage calls them objects
instead not because they are not like
files but because files are generally
stored in a file system and the file
systems we are used to interacting with
on modern operating systems generally
have a hierarchical structure and naming
conventions that cloud storage does not
have thus cloud storage calls the place
you store things a bucket and the things
that you store objects let's use the
developer console to get started with
cloud storage this project does not
currently have any buckets so let's
create one first you have to choose a
name for the bucket it's important to
note that bucket names are global across
all projects if you try to create a
bucket with an obvious name such as test
you will probably find that the bucket
name is not available as you can see the
developer console helpfully checks your
bucket name while you're typing it to
let you know if it's a legal name and if
it's available now we have a legal and
available bucket name but we still have
a couple of choices to make the first is
the class of storage to use standard
storage is the default and if you're
using cloud storage as part of an
application is almost always the right
choice
it provides the best latency and highest
availability of the storage classes
which is usually what you want if for
some reason you can accept a lower
availability for the objects you are
storing in this bucket you can choose
the durable reduced availability class
of storage instead as the name implies
objects stored with this class of
storage are just as durable as standard
but have a reduced availability
expectation the service level agreement
for the standard storage class specifies
99.9% availability the durable reduced
availability class specifies 99 percent
availability instead the trade-off for
accepting the reduced availability
expectation is a lower price pricing is
subject to change so you should consult
a current price list for details in the
cost of the different classes of storage
the final class of storage is Nearline
Nearline storage is intended for
archival scenarios where you do not
expect to access the stored objects
often Nearline storage also carries a
99% available of the SLA Nearline
storage also has slightly higher latency
than standard or durable reduced
availability storage with an expectation
of a few seconds to the first byte
compared with less than a second to the
first byte for the other classes of
storage Nearline storage is
significantly less expensive than
standard or durable reduced availability
storage but there is a surcharge for
accessing your objects a good rule of
thumb for when to use Nearline storage
is that if you think you will access an
object less than once a month
the Nearline storage will probably be
the more cost-effective option if you
expect to access an object more than
once a month
durable reduced availability storage
will be more cost effective the second
choice is the location where your data
will be stored there are two types of
locations available multi-regional and
regional regional locations correspond
to the region's supported in other cloud
platform services such as compute engine
if you primarily intend to
read and write to this bucket from
compute engine instances in a particular
region then setting the location of the
bucket to that same region will provide
lower latency and higher throughput for
that workload
however by setting the location to a
particular region you restrict the
storage to only that region which can be
a disadvantage if your objects are going
to be accessed from many different
places if your objects will be accessed
from many different places then you can
choose a multi region location which
restricts the placement of your data to
a broader geographic area currently the
choices are Asia the European Union and
the United States these multi region
locations can also be useful when you
want to ensure your data stays within a
certain jurisdiction with these choices
made you can now create your bucket here
we see our new bucket which is of course
empty we could use the developer console
to upload objects but instead I would
like to quickly show you how to use the
command line utility GS util that comes
with the Google Cloud SDK I have
previously installed the Google Cloud
SDK and configured it to point to the
project and use my credentials we can
use gsutil to see the bucket we just
created using the LS command gsutil
uses a URI syntax for object names where
the GS prefix specifies objects stored
in Google Cloud storage
it can also access files in the local
filesystem and objects stored in Amazon
s3 using the s3 prefix which is useful
for transferring objects between cloud
storage and the local filesystem or
between cloud storage and Amazon s3 here
I will quickly demonstrate how to upload
a large number of objects in a single
command and we can switch back to the
developer console refresh the window and
see those objects in our bucket now
let's take a quick hands-on tour of the
structured storage options starting with
cloud sequel when we click on cloud
sequel we are given the opportunity to
create a cloud sequel instance we choose
a name for the instance which must be
unique within this project choose a
region in which to run the instance and
a size for the instance
there are lots of additional
configuration options that I won't go
into detail on now but the one I wanted
to point out is database version the
important thing to notice is that you
are selecting an explicit my sequel
version this demonstrates a key point
about cloud sequel it is a hosted my
sequel service it is not similar to my
sequel it is my sequel whatever you do
today with my sequel you can do with
cloud sequel but Google takes care of
keeping the operating system up to date
configuring replication performing
backups and other ops tasks to
underscore the point that this really is
a my sequel server we started let's
connect to it using the my sequel client
let's create a new instance we can use
to run the my sequel client because this
instance is part of the same project no
additional network configuration is
required however we do need to make sure
we enable access to cloud sequel for
this instance we can do this explicitly
in access and security or we can allow
this instance to access all cloud
resources that are part of this project
since we may use this instance for more
than just running the my sequel client
we will enable access to all the api's
with this checkbox
once the instance is created we can SSH
into it and install the my sequel client
via apt-get however we need to make a
couple of configuration changes to our
cloud sequel instance before we can
connect to it first we need an ipv4
address to connect to then we need to
tell cloud sequel that we're okay with
connections coming from the IP address
of our compute engine instance in this
example we only want one compute engine
instance to get access so we specify a
network with a 32-bit prefix which
effectively means a single host finally
we need an account that allows us to
sign in from our host the default root
accounts only work from localhost so we
create a new account that allows root to
sign in from our instances IP address
now we are ready to connect to our cloud
sequel instance using the my sequel
client at this point you have a fully
functional my sequel prompt with which
you can do all the normal stuff you
would expect to be able to do from a
root my sequel prompt such as creating
new databases creating too
Able's and so on by now you get the idea
that cloud sequel is a fully functional
my sequel database which is fantastic if
what you want is a low maintenance my
sequel instance it has everything you
expect from sequel a rich query language
primary and secondary indexes acid
transactions relational integrity stored
procedures the works if you are familiar
with my sequel or another relational
database and you value the power of a
full relational database and if your
scalability needs are not too great
cloud sequel could be the perfect
solution for your application however
the so-called no sequel family of
databases was created to address some of
the issues faced by relational databases
when maintaining relational integrity
and full acid semantics while attempting
to attain massive scale in a
cost-effective way which brings us to
cloud datastore cloud datastore was born
as the structured storage solution for
App Engine but is now accessible from
outside of App Engine as well cloud
datastore scales gracefully from very
small database sizes to very large
database sizes it grows with your
application both in terms of scale and
by being flexible when it comes to
schema definition for those of you who
are accustomed to third normal form with
full relational integrity you may find
the no sequel approach to scam a
definition to be a little bit fast and
loose and you'd be right it is fast by
which I mean highly scalable and it is
loose by which I mean it is highly
flexible there is no equivalent to a
create table statement in cloud
datastore you simply start storing
things there is no equivalent to an
alter table statement to add new columns
you just start storing things with
additional columns we can demonstrate
this in the developers console there are
a few important things to notice about
what we're doing here while this may
look a little like defining a table it's
not what we're doing is storing the very
first entity of its kind in our projects
datastore we can then store a second
entity of the same kind but we can add
new properties to it that we're not in
the first entity you'll see when we
create a second entity it knows which of
the first entities properties were
marked as being indexed
and asks us for a value for those but it
does not demand that we provide a value
for every property that was in the first
entity in fact you can even create
entities that do not have values for
properties that were previously
identified as being indexed at this
point it bears mentioning that just
because cloud datastore doesn't require
you to define your schema in advance
doesn't mean you don't need to think
very carefully about your data model you
still need to think carefully about what
you're planning to store and how you
intend to retrieve it but the no sequel
approach means that when the time comes
to store additional information about a
kind which in a sequel world would mean
an alter table statement to add columns
to a table you can simply start storing
new entities of that kind with the
additional information you now require
you'll need a plan to either backfill
old data or deal with entities that are
missing that data but that's true no
matter what your database may look like
another thing to notice is that at no
point did we tell the datastore how many
resources should be used for our
structured data it is a true no opt
solution with almost no operational
overhead no need to specify instance
sizes or cluster sizes or anything of
that nature datastore is a great fit for
an application database that scales from
zero to terabytes of data as your
application grows in popularity however
if your scaling needs are truly massive
there is another no sequel solution you
should consider cloud BigTable cloud
BigTable is a hosted version of the same
BigTable technology that Google has been
using internally for over a decade in
2006 Google published a paper describing
BigTable which resulted in a flurry of
activity in the open-source community to
build similar systems one of those open
source projects inspired by BigTable was
H bass which is part of the larger
Hadoop ecosystem cloud BigTable is
exposed through the HBase API which
makes it instantly compatible with a
great deal of existing code written for
the Hadoop ecosystem but it is a managed
service which reduces your operational
overhead if you know you're going to be
storing over a terabyte of structured
data if you have a very high volume of
writes if you need read
right latency in the single-digit
millisecond range with strong
consistency or if you're already using
HBase and you want a straightforward
migration path to a managed cloud
service cloud BigTable is something you
should look into let's create our very
own cloud BigTable cluster to see what
that looks like we have a couple of
choices to make at this point first is
to choose the zone in which our cluster
will run we called it for cloud sequel
we selected a region and for cloud
datastore we selected nothing we simply
started storing data and let cloud
datastore worry about where it should go
cloud BigTable is a lower-level database
than both cloud sequel and cloud
datastore which is one of the reasons it
can scale so high and provide such low
latency but with such low latency
guarantees your whole cluster runs in a
single zone the second choice is how
many nodes to provision as we increase
the number of nodes we increase the
available operations per second and
throughput and also of course the cost
you can go up to 30 nodes without even
talking to us as the developer console
shows a 30 node cluster is capable of
performing 300,000 operations per second
with a throughput of 300 megabytes per
second to put that in perspective 300
megabytes per second is about 25
terabytes per day which would add up to
about 9 petabytes in a year that scale
similar to how we use the native my
sequel client to demonstrate the cloud
sequel really is my sequel I'm going to
demonstrate how we can use the HBase
client to connect to our cloud BigTable
cluster Here I am using the QuickStart
script that is described in the cloud
BigTable quick start setting up the
HBase client can be tricky and the quick
start package in script makes sure you
have the right things on your machine
and understands how to discover and
connect to your cloud BigTable cluster
we can see that we don't currently have
any tables in our cluster so we create
one then add a row to it then scan the
table to verify the row is there
learning how to model data in BigTable
and use the HBase API is beyond the
scope of this video but this short
example serves to show that cloud
BigTable doesn't
you'd play nicely with the HBase
toolchain given the massive scalability
provided by cloud BigTable why not make
it your number one choice after all
everyone wants to be prepared for the
overwhelming success of their
application so why not choose the most
scalable database available simply put
cloud BigTable does not effectively
scale down to small sizes the smallest
cloud BigTable cluster you can create
still has three nodes and can handle
30,000 operations per second which is
far more than a small application needs
this isn't a problem from a performance
standpoint but it is a problem from a
cost-effectiveness perspective these
three nodes are dedicated for your sole
use and cost the same per hour no matter
if you use them or not contrast this
with cloud data storage model where you
pay by the operation so when your usage
is small so is your cost each of the
structured storage solutions we have
discussed so far cloud sequel cloud
datastore and cloud BigTable are
primarily operational databases they are
intended to be used as part of an
application
the final structured storage service
we're going to talk about is bigquery
which is an analytical database the
power of bigquery is its ability to run
sequel queries over terabytes of data in
seconds to demonstrate I will use one of
the several public data sets available
in bigquery this data set contains 100
billion rows of page view data from the
wikimedia foundation by running this row
count query we can see that there are
indeed more than 100 billion rows in
this table now we are going to scan all
hundred billion of those rows run a
regular expression against each one then
aggregate the page views for each
matching row and there we have it we
just scanned over 3 terabytes of data in
less than a minute I hope you've enjoyed
this whirlwind tour of the storage
options in the Google cloud platform we
were barely able to scratch the surface
of each of these great products but
hopefully you have a better idea of
which ones might be best for your
application